Paul I know you and a lot of the writers
eventually went on to freakazoid and
something very interesting that I
noticed is that Tiny Toons was very much
children oriented entertainment
Animaniacs was sort of both children and
adults
freakazoid seemed very much surreal odd
adult humor and again what was there
sort of a conscious effort to follow the
age of your audience as they got older
it could be that that we were sort of
ready to write that when freakazoid came
along I was originally a little hesitant
to sort of get into because it was a
superhero thing but then once we started
writing it and realized it didn't really
have to be a superhero kind of thing it
just had to be really weird and fun and
dumb then that's what we started writing
so I don't know if it was a conscious
decision from anybody but it just felt
like this is what we really feel like
writing now Tom I've sort of a weird
question I just have to relate too much
here but it's something that's driven me
nuts for a really really long time uh my
favorite cartoon is hooked on a ceiling
which is where the waters help
Michelangelo paint the Sistine Chapel
and to me that's about as perfect as a
cartoon that you can get but why was
Michelangelo portrayed as Kirk Douglas
out you incompetent fools you call
yourselves artists instead of Charlton
Heston who played Michelangelo and agony
of the ecstasy jet why Kirk Douglas
that's a really good question that is
like I think like the definitive
Warner's cartoon it's like a perfect
cartoon it's beautifully done
you know I here's my guess we had this
great caricature of Kirk Douglas we
didn't have such a great drawing of
Charlton Heston also the voice for Kirk
is so much funnier than Charlton at
least what we were doing with Charlton
you fools I'm the great Michelangelo and
this is the Sistine Chapel oh yeah if
you're so great what did you do with the
other 15 chapels huh today I think I had
to do with performance and drawing in
that case I guess we could have been
parodying the movie closer with Charlton
but yeah it worked after the success of
Warner Brothers all of you of course
went on to do various different things
what have you guys been up to like Nate
did you ever consider going back to the
voice acting at all I
did think about going back into voice
acting but then puberty hit and my voice
cracked and that pretty much killed my
career as a child voice actor just so
you know they were actually digitally
pitching my voice higher at the end of
Animaniacs because my voice had
noticeably changed
let's not bond his mom's he's old I'm
Betty peanuts and popcorn is Dodger dogs
go far and so I guess I'm offended going
back into voice acting I have been
working my way back into Hollywood as a
writer director and just recently I
finished a short film called another
life it's an neo noir thriller about a
young female veteran who has three days
to kill an innocent man or they both die
not a comedy that so the rest of you
guys what do you been up to ever since
the success of Animaniacs I've been
gardening I've been sitting on my
laurels mostly uh you know just trying
to milk it as much as I can after
freakazoid I did a stint at with Peter
Hastings at Disney one Saturday morning
and I did a live-action character for
him called mana Dane County Moffett I
asked fans that I meet on Facebook and
other places for cash or to sign a loan
produced and started at a show called
Animalia for PBS did something called
sushi pack you know I sold a pilot to
Nickelodeon I'm working on Kung Fu Panda
way a whoop Kung Fu Panda like the movie
it's called legends of Awesomeness it's
the it's the Nick TV show so it's CCG
but it's a half-hour stories and John
outside of begging your fans
what do you been doing with your time
then writing more short fiction actually
I'm working on my first novel right now
which is kind of kind of fun I pitch a
lot of stuff I'm getting together with a
lot of the people you're interviewing
for this to pitch a new show and can I
ask what that's about
it's about a flock of vultures it's the
first to my knowledge the first totally
improv animated sitcom pilot gathered
together a couple of very funny actors
Paul rug and John McCann Sherri stoner
Indiana Oliver gathered in a recording
studio by the end of the day they had
improved
entirely new animated sitcom that sounds
awesome I'm gonna support this I'm going
to get behind this show I want you to
make it happen yeah you think
Spielberg's name carries a lot of fun
than this value pretty okay household
name everybody knows me is Phil Berg
like some people in China know I don't
know we're gonna fly you out here you're
gonna improv with these people that's
right that's right good my methods of
improv are very good ish so uh now how
about you Shari yeah what do you been
doing with your time well I'm a mother
certainly I'm working on a couple of
projects of my own that hopefully see
the light of day very very soon can you
tell us about any of these projects Oh
beau come on Tom told us about improv
ulcers oh well see well he's tricky all
right all right but because of that you
guys throw everybody off by saying who's
your favorite character Animaniacs well
it has to be see I I mean it was sort of
self-loathing if I didn't say slappy in
a way wouldn't it let's skip it this
girl's the best obviously I made him two
best probably yeah go probably Yakko I
have to go with yeah I know a lot of
other people like yeah Nicole might be
prosaic I'm gonna go and whack up all
right and technically the last question
I'm gonna ask you guys is uh what's your
favorite episode that any of you worked
out I like cookies for Einstein because
I was desperate to find a way to end it
and my wife suggested that Acme
backwards was sort of like e equals MC
squared so I sort of liked that one I
think I've two one is bumbie's mom and
the other would be Bubba Bo Bob brain
yeah I really have to name my favorite
yes and you only have five seconds five
four three two except it's a toss-up
between Woodstock slappy and star
Warner's you still don't win the car I
really enjoyed space probed you know I
loved science fiction and I you know was
able to include a lot of the films that
I really liked I think episode 85 has a
the two note song where Wakko
is trying to convince dr. scratchansniff
that you can still make music and of
just two notes in that song does this
childlike joy and wonder in finding
beauty and even the simplest music now
there's two more people I would like to
talk to if I can ah Paul I would like to
talk with mr. director is it possible to
speak with him absolutely absolutely
mr. director in your professional
opinion what is the secret of comedy
timing timing good coffee uh many words
that that the people you're talking to
don't really understand is an effect
ation of brilliance that you exude from
your own pause to cause the others to be
flattered with your perspiration now I'm
also wondering do you understand what
I'm saying
you're getting it because I'm trying to
talk and you're not there's nothing man
go ahead but mr. director uh directing
is obviously in your name but I have to
admit I haven't seen any of the films
that you have worked on what are some of
the films that you've directed the tin
boy it was about a boy who was tin and a
rust came and was very sad
Sh'ma Kela I don't know if you saw that
it was was a was a Jewish vampire I
don't know if you saw that very good um
the glass people Lumpkin flunkin was
good and bashed with Nibin how that last
one go again but I hear say it with me
say boss bushka car believe in pubic
bush good woman could you give me a plot
synopsis on that one by the should yes
there was a man made of dough Wow
he was formed in the oven much like a
creator or God would form you and he was
made of dough but his arm was because of
a baking accident or something on was
backwards from the rest of his body and
this caused in him to be mocked to be
ridiculed
and so it's about him finding someone to
chew his arm off Wow that that's very
moving I got it no no no I was talking
about toddy my fest with it I'm just
that's just the first three pages oh
really
after that there's a war he goes to a
fairyland
where there are fireballs and he's
eventually reformed in a new dough and
is made whole this is so like a fairy
tale from Tommy Wiseau I won an award in
Cleveland no kidding
and what was that called the award of
Cleveland I'm not saying it was it was
clever but that's what's called the
award of Cleveland for that that being
my movie now mr. director I recall a
character a clown specifically who was
hired to terrorize Wakko at one point
and I must say he bears an unbelievable
likeness to you even has a very similar
voice hello I'm a poppy bug laven was
distant relative which is very
interesting here and I will tell this to
no one else uh that I had a desperate
time things were not working well for me
I was in foreclosure on a boat but I
lived on and in order to pay the bills I
hate to admit this I had to do that part
and that was actually me um but in
hindsight I think it was brilliant there
was talk of me winning an Emmy but I
didn't because I didn't but there was
talk of it and do you ever have any
temptations about returning to the clown
hood to the clown hood yeah it's not a
gang film starring balls away I didn't
stay for me singing songs Bing silly
making
see just when you mention it there you
bring it out of me
so excuse me but that had to come out
sorry
if it's cool I will know nothing about
sudden impulses now mr. director very
last question uh in your opinion again
your professional opinion what is funny
what is the absolute bare essence of
funny
all right here's go with me on a thought
experiment okay you're in a jungle
there's an elephant and it's chasing you
the elephant knocks you to the ground
I'm still going with this I'm never done
so totally but it's most brilliant more
than you can understand
repeat after me I'm in the jungle I'm in
the jungle an elephant's chasing me an
elephant is chasing it knocked me down
and knocked me down and then it makes a
poop that's pretty much you didn't
expect it did did did did you know I may
not to be there but then a living
elephant yeah I know I have to admit I
did not see that coming that's comedy
thank you so much mr. director I can see
why they call you a genius thank you now
uh Cherie is there any chance we can
talk to slappy squirrel for a moment Oh
to my buzz okay yeah slappy what has
happened with cartoons nowadays I mean
they just don't seem as funny as they
were in the old days yeah they're no
good I'll tell you why that the hiring
hacks to be in a bunch of prima donna
hacks and don't know how to take any
dynamite to the head nobody's falling
down anymore nobody's getting hurt they
just stand there and yak yak yak yak yak
when's the last time the family guy got
hit on the head with a mallet you ain't
gonna see it no slap you've obviously
known a lot of cartoon characters have
gotten the dirt on a good chunk of them
tell me who is the most shocking that
you ever had to work with Judy Jetson
really I would have guessed that yeah
Judy Jetson was was a handful to me
Lindsay Lohan looked like Shirley Temple
you know what I'm talking about
she was a mess a nightmare never wore
underpants no kidding oh I'll have to
watch more the Jetsons now we all know
that olive oil has never been the same
ever since her breast reduction but what
I'm wondering is did any of that have to
do with Popeye spinach abuse did you
know the couple well we was very true to
these rumors it was sad really you know
pull olive oil well nowadays they would
have probably put her in some sort of
rehab facility for eating disorders but
in her day it was just lose weight it's
funny lose weight it's funny you know
turn sideways can't see you that sort of
thing and the poor girl went for it she
finally went invisible completely no
one's heard of her I always suspected
that Woody Woodpecker was a pill-popper
was there any suspicion that he had an
addictive personality yeah it was a he
was a wood addict oak no well that's
tragic couldn't get enough of the stuff
used to call him a little pecker he was
to slappy what do you think about
cartoon characters nowadays like oh no
what do you think about spongebob now
you know I adored that spongebob what a
nice kid he's written me so many fan
letters yeah he was camped out on my
lawn you know he's almost a stalker
really he's a very very nice guy and
very subdued in real life very calm very
zen you know he's a Buddhist I did not
know that what are the wisest
individuals I've ever met Dennis slappy
you have a nephew named Skippy and you
two obviously spend a lot of time
together but it almost seems like he's
living with you you're practically
taking care of him uh we're his parents
that was sabbatical that's all Wow they
went on a cruise shortly after uh Skippy
was born in
they haven't returned the see end of
world seeing the sights living the high
life
we don't speak much but they're very
kind yeah they sound real attentive
there they sound like real caring people
and I say they send me a check every
month
not the slappy I got one last question
for you are you aware of a woman named
Sherry's donor yes what were your
impressions on her she's very tiny and
that's all I got guys thank you so much
for doing this this was just so frigging
awesome one final thing I just want you
to be able to see that oh you know we
want a bunch of Emmys so you know and
what do you do with these things so what
we did was we we planted a couple and we
got a crop oh wow
yeah so you know we better bring in this
crop every year that's a very impressive
gras so and then we you know in
Halloween we hand them out because yeah
what do you do with them we're gonna
ship out a lot of these to you
nostalgia critic as as soon as as soon
as we can Thank You Thom Ruhe Grammy
I'll put that right next to my Roger
Ebert Twitter guys thank you so much for
doing this this is just a dream come
true
I love Animaniacs I love the work you
guys put into it I think it's a
wonderful show I really think it holds
up thank you all for doing this again I
have one last question and that question
is for Nate Nate I know it's been
several years ago but I simply got to
ask can you see water go down the hole
oh my god man you really want me to say
that you really want me to say that
again yes yes then what would go down
the hole I'm 26 years old it's been 17
years I'm a grown man what the fact that
you're a grown man just say the line
go on say it set hot water go down the
hole
that was wonderful
no say it while wearing a dime no chance
in hell hey hey where you going don't
you run away from me
I'm supporting your dad's weird vulture
idea Nate night-night you fluffy tail
bastard I'll get you for this you will
say that line while wearing a diaper
first you and then one day your ass whoa
winner if you go down the hole
water go down the hole